if we can't start stopping the bleeding
this year we're not sure we'll be around
by next year
that is a startling admission from
Public Safety leaders if lawmakers don't
raise pay there may be no Nevada State
Police it's a crisis our 8 news now
investigators have covered for more than
a year fewer troopers on the road
affecting your safety eight news now
investigator David charns with the
impact on one local family David well
the clock is ticking on the legislature
to do something as more Troopers leave
Highway Patrol every week our
investigation finding there isn't 24 7
coverage on some of our busiest roads
including the highway where a driver is
accused of claiming this 18 year old's
life too soon
Greg what makes you unaware of that UNLV
gear right now
my daughter Greg and Alexandra Johnson's
Pride for their 18 year old daughter Kat
beams brightly from halfway across the
country in Tennessee one thing they're
gonna take away from me is to always be
a UNLV dad from now on cat came to Las
Vegas to study computer science and
coding by the end of September
suspected impaired driver would take her
life on September 26 around midnight Kat
was driving here on the 95 just outside
of Boulder City another driver was
headed south and for reasons unknown she
crossed the center line colliding into
cat head on Taylor Madison told police
she thought she was drugged documents
say the trooper who arrested her could
quote smell the strong odor of alcohol
on her police say they found a white
powdery substance and marijuana in her
car well Madison was in a hospital bed
the coroner was calling said uh I'm
sorry that your daughter was killed in a
head-on collision it's with the DOI
driver the crash happened at 12 33 a.m
on a section of Road in the jurisdiction
of Nevada State Police but records the
eight news now investigators obtained
show Boulder City police arrived first
at 12 41. its firefighters were there
two minutes later at 12 43. the first
state trooper arrived at 1 14 nearly 45
minutes after impact you're going to be
waiting Wayne dice is a spokesman for
the Nevada police Union which represents
Nevada State Police a force with fewer
people to its name every day we're
having a problem with people being able
to respond to crashes because we don't
have enough people last year the 8 news
now investigators reported the shortage
was so bad there may be as few as three
or four Troopers patrolling the entire
Las Vegas Valley overnight that means
Troopers are going from stop to stop
crash to crash where every minute counts
that's our responsibility to show up and
make sure that we control that scene and
start that investigation make sure it's
all safe for everyone and if those folks
are on crashes or in the jail there's
nobody out there patrolling the freeways
looking for some pair drivers suspected
impaired drivers like Taylor Madison who
Troopers say was on the wrong side of
the road before the car she was driving
became a weapon data from the Department
reveals a 32 vacancy rate for sworn
officers out of 389 positions
123 need to be filled the eight new Zeal
investigators finding there are some
parts of Nevada with no coverage
substations in Eureka Indian Springs and
Lovelock have no Troopers in Boulder
City covering the area of cats crash
there are six authorized Physicians
three are vacant the 8 news now
investigative is learning there is no
coverage after 10 o'clock on this artery
in and out of the valley here's the
deputy director of the Department of
Public Safety during a hearing just days
ago the idea that we're 24 7 on the
highways is is just not true at all in
fact it's it's rare
especially outside the cities that right
there criminals don't take a time off
drunk drivers don't take a time off the
crisis the union says is a product of
Nevada's own making state troopers make
on average 24 percent less than other
police departments raises hopefully
ensures retention Republican Governor
Joe Lombardo wants to close that Gap his
proposal would give State Police a bump
but starting this July more money will
be taken out of their paychecks for
retirement nearly 30 percent of their
salaries state law requires state
employees pay their own retirement
benefits do you feel like Nevada is
failing you I don't know what's going to
take for the legislature to understand
this
I hate to have one of their family
members
be killed by a DUI driver and that's
what finally tips the hand for us to get
some help and it shouldn't take that
every day is hard and it doesn't get
easier the Johnsons believe their
daughter died seconds after the crash I
honestly did not realize that it took
nhp that long to respond they questioned
what happened in those 45 minutes before
that Trooper arrived before the
investigation into their daughter's
death officially began I understand that
maybe they deal with this stuff on a
daily basis but that's my only daughter
and I can't get that back
tonight Taylor Madison is out on bond a
bond higher than a judge initially said
about two months after that crash a
judge found her out of compliance and
tripled that amount she is out of
custody now on 150 thousand dollars bail
I'm David charns 8 News Now